RICH HYNDMAN:
Android Marshmallow
is coming to devices soon.
And just like every
new Android release,
it's important to make sure
that your app is up to date
and ready to be installed as
soon as the upgrade rolls out.
My name is Rich
Hyndman, and I'm here
with a quick update to using the
developer preview to get ready
for launch.
Let's jump right in.
The Android M
developer preview three
consists of the
final Android 6 SDK.
It's got documentation, sample
code, and near-final emulator
and device images.
We've incremented the
API level to 23 now,
so you can upload your
Marshmallow targeted apps
to the Play Store and make use
of the alpha and beta channels.
If you've been following
along through dev previews
one and two, then this
update is pretty incremental.
We've enhanced the permissions,
user interface and behavior
and also updated the fingerprint
API to give a better enrollment
experience, enumeration support,
and improved error reporting.
You can check the
API differences
doc for full details.
If you've not already flashed
a device to the developer
preview, then it's
worth pointing out
that you should grab
the latest SDK first.
Open up Android Studio.
There's no need for preview
or Canary channels this time
as we're on the final SDK so
head straight into your SDK
manager.
You have access to the final
Android 6 APIs and the latest
build tools so you
can target API 23.
Whilst you're there, you should
update to the new Android
support library as well.
It contains a number of
new support libraries,
including custom tabs,
percentage-based measurements,
recommendation, and preferences.
And you're all ready to go.
If you're starting
a new project,
you can choose target
SDK API 23 and ignore
the fact it says Android 5.x.
We'll fix that before
the actual release.
If you're updating an existing
developer preview project,
you're now switching your
build from using Android
MNC as your SDK version to 23.
You can also head
to the AVD manager
if you want to set
up an emulator.
Select a device of your choice
and use the API 23 x86 images
for best performance.
OK, back to the device images.
So ensure your data's backed
up and follow the steps
in the preview guide.
If your Bootloader is
locked, then you'll
have to unlock it first.
So ensure, if you're on
a Nexus 6 or a Nexus 9,
that OEM unlocking is enabled
in the developer options.
Then ADB to reboot
into Bootloader,
run fastboot OEM
Unlock, which is also
going to wipe your data.
Then you're going to
go to the system images
and execute the
flash-all script.
It's going to update your
device's Bootloader, baseband,
firmware, and OS.
Then to be secure,
it's recommended
to lock your Bootloader
again with fastboot OEM lock.
It should be smooth sailing.
And if you do hit a
missing system.image error,
then you're probably not
using the latest SDK tools.
Now you have an Android M
device for testing and a preview
emulator.
As always with new releases, we
have some changes in behavior
that you'll need to test out.
You can find them all
on the Behavior Changes
page on the preview site.
First up, a deprecated
API that's been removed.
If your app or any of
the libraries you use
rely on the Apache
HTTP client, you're
going to need to make a
small update to include it
in your build and declare it
as a compile time dependency
in your build.gradle file.
If your app targets
Android 2.3 or higher,
I would highly
recommend switching
to the more efficient HTTP
URL connection class instead.
Next up, we have Doze.
If a user leaves a device
unplugged and stationary
for a short period of
time with the screen off,
the device is going
to enter Doze mode.
It's going to try
and stay asleep
until the device is disturbed.
Restrictions will apply
to your app in this mode.
Wake locks are ignored,
sync adapters can't sync,
scheduled alarms are deferred,
and network access is disabled.
You can enable some of these,
so check the documentation
on power-saving optimizations
for more details.
To test Doze mode, we
have ADB commands here.
There's also App Standby mode,
which can detect and affect
inactive apps.
So check that out as well.
Excitingly, runtime
permissions are here.
They provide less friction
on install and automatic app
updates.
But you can no longer assume
that just because your app is
installed all its stated
permissions have been granted.
Permissions are
granted at runtime,
and users can revoke permissions
on a per-app basis at any time,
even for legacy apps that
aren't targeting Android M.
For testing, we have
more all-new ADB commands
for parameters for granting
permissions, revoking
permissions, installing
apps with all
the permissions granted.
Check out the Permissions
Guide on the preview
site for details.
Always check that you have a
permission before trying to use
it and request it if you don't.
If there's a set of permissions
that your app needs,
like camera access
for a camera app,
it can be worth requesting
them in a warm welcome upfront.
Next, Android Auto Backup.
It's a new service designed to
simplify building a robust data
backup service for developers
and improve the lives of users.
Up to 25 megabytes of
data is backed up per app.
Watch Matthew's video
for full details.
If your project
targets them, backup
will be automatically
enabled, and there
were a couple of things
you should be aware of.
If you have any data you
don't want backed up,
like device-specific
or encrypted data,
then the easiest
thing to do is move it
into the Get No Backup
Files directory.
You can also specify an
inclusive or exclusive
backup scheme or
opt out altogether.
For testing, there are new ADB
Shell backup manager commands.
And as I say in the
M preview build,
Auto Backup is
enabled for all apps.
For the M release,
we will only do it
for apps that are
targeted M or higher.
It's also worth mentioning
that for testing we
have new fingerprint APIs
and the new ADB Finger Touch
command to go along for
simulating fingerprint input.
Check the preview site
and [? Maya's ?] video
for full details.
So, we're on preview three.
We're on the home straight
to the final release.
So please ensure
your apps are ready.
Check out the preview
for other features
like app standby, adoptable
storage, data binding, text
selection, and the very
powerful app linking.
Test now while you have time,
and you can give us feedback
in the Android M developer
community on Google+.
So that's Android Marshmallow,
something harmless
and lovable that could never
possibly run amok in New York
and destroy us.